[Music]
today in Walter mat home cooking is all
about wonderful light dishes packed with
flavor one of the tricks to making great
food at home is having a range of
different dishes up your sleep sometimes
you want food that's rich and comforting
other times you want to keep it nice
light and fresh but it's all about
making your cooking interesting so get
ready for plenty of zingy citrus flavors
these are my ultimate Light Recipes
first up a lovely light breakfast of
avocado on sourdough toast with lemon
and black sesame sprinkle light healthy
quick but so tasty for lunch an
incredible mackerel Ceviche with
grapefruit and Shea fennel salad that
cured lightly pickled Ceviche flavor is
incredible served with delicious super
healthy quinoa salad no wonder I'm so
thin and Holly shows off her cooking
prowess when we team up to cook dinner
good girl you're faster than Jack don't
tell him for starters a feta and
watermelon salad I know you're dying to
get in there aren't you
for Maine griddle chicken thighs with
chickpeas and a lemony dressing oh that
juicy amazing chicken and for desserts a
cool soothing lemon and basil granita oh
gorgeous is that
three great tasting like meals to leave
you feeling refreshed and satisfied
through breakfast lunch and dinner
starting with the breakfast that won't
weigh you down
sourdough bread with crushed avocado
you think of the flavor and the texture
of avocado Rich phenomenal I want to
make it a little bit more vibrant
black sesame seeds a nice pinch of chili
flakes I quite like it hot
Touch of salt
a touch of pepper
so that nice dry combination of the
lemon zest black sesame seeds and the
heat from chili this is light healthy
quick
but so tasty sourdough bread
three nice chunky thick slices open them
up
let me season them
little touch of olive oil
brings the Whole Crust to life
rub all that seasoning in but you can
use tea butter you can use a baguette
but the richness from the sourdough or
the silky creaminess of avocado is
mind-blowing and then get the grill up
to temperature
push these down go the extra mile we've
all put bread in a toaster for the
difference
grilling the bread this way
extraordinary that nice Smoky charcoal
flavor
off with the gas beautiful
now the avocado you've got to treat them
with love respect press on the end here
add your thumb
softens you can tell that avocado is
ripe never press here you just end up
bruising it
slice down
to fill that stone in the middle and
then just roll around and then it's just
a little gentle twist
off Stone
and out cut them into quarters
the back of your knife peel back that
skin if you have a color is nice and
ripe it should just all fall away slice
just take your quarters fan them out
push them into the breath
The Ripe of the avocado the better the
flavor but look for ones free from soft
spots and blemishes which can suggest
bruising
get your lemon
squeeze that will stop the avocado from
discoloring
and get your crunch ready to go on top
sprinkle a very generous light way but
the fragrance from the lemon zest
the crunch from the sesame seed the heat
that little chili flake which just wakes
up the avocado
Hey look
expensive
that for me is a delicious light start
to the day
avocado on sourdough toast with lemon
and black sesame sprinkle
next I'll be showing you a stunning
light luncheon dinner but first here's a
quick guide to some of the key
ingredients you'll need to make them
thank you
as unique Tangy sharp lemony flavor
sumac is a prized spice used to bring
life to many Mediterranean and Middle
Eastern dishes
whole crushed or ground sumac berries
can be added to marinades dressings
sauces or yogurt
and it's dry powdered form sumac will
add a kick to salads chicken or fish
dishes
but use this powerful spice sparingly a
sprinkling is enough
[Music]
along with olive oil and uzo feta cheese
made from cheese milk or sheep and
goat's milk is one of Greece's most
famous exports
like bread Creeks will serve feta
alongside most meals
with a strong salty flavor is used to
season and enrich slow cooked meats
stews and cut into rustic chunks along
with cucumber tomato and olives feta
puts the Greek in gutsy Creek salad
oh
I'll be making a fruity light feta salad
for dinner tonight
[Music]
regarded as a mother grain of the
ancient Peruvian Inca tribes quinoa has
been grown in the high Andes for
thousands of years
[Music]
prepare its fluffy texture and subtle
nutty flavor makes it an excellent
alternative to rice or couscous
this small gluten-free seed was recently
hailed as an international superfood
not only does it contain all eight
essential amino acids
but is packed with fiber phosphorus
magnesium and iron
when I first started cooking
professionally pretty much all the
high-end British restaurants serve very
rich French inspired food lots of sauces
lots of cream and butter nervous but
what I've tried to do in my versions is
keep the Finesse and flavor but make my
food much much lighter poor color I'm
looking at that level of fat in there as
well and I've done the same thing at
home too so for my ultimate light lunch
I'm using lots of raw ingredients herbs
and citrus flavors mackerel cevise with
the most amazing crisp delicious fennel
salad
mackerel is incredible cheap but so
delicious and Ceviche just means
basically marinating but the secret is
in the dressing
it's been grapefruit take the top off
on the bottom and don't slice off too
much to begin with otherwise you'll
regret it keep your knife nice and flat
and just start peeling
twist and you see how thick the pith is
just follow with your knife
nothing worse when you're doing this it
comes out like a hexagon or 50 pence
piece
you can do this dressing with lemons
limes oranges but there's something
quite useful about a pink grapefruit
turn it over
and double check a little bit there
really important to get rid of all the
pith slice each side of your pith that
keeps all those segments together
there's the line slice down slice in
give that a little stir whisk it and it
starts to separate all those little
segments
season it
olive oil
these are little fennel prongs amazing
flavor gives a really nice aniseedy
delicious freshness it always frustrates
me how many people throw that away
because the flavor in there is fantastic
in a fish top incredible in a
vinaigrette had that man
next chop coriander
Fisher is served in his marinade
something quite picturesque when you see
all that listening save a little touch
of your dressing for the fennel
now your macro it's been filleted and
pin boned
rinse your knife and just slice through
bite-sized chunks
Seviche is popular in Spain and South
America is always made from raw fish or
seafood cured in a citrus dressing
the less you handle the mackerel the
better it is when you start mixing up
and tossing and turning it you lose the
texture the fresh the mackerel is the
better it will taste but when you're
serving it raw like this make sure it
really is fresh out of the sea
just lightly seasoned
so that Chevy say starts to cure and
marinade that mackerel
finish that with thin little shards of
pink grapefruit and then just
a little drizzle of olive oil on top
leave that to sit
I always like marinating my mackerel
literally an hour before when I eat it
that kind of cured lightly pickled
Ceviche flavor that is incredible
to go with my Ceviche for my ultimate
light lunch a beautiful quinoa salad
with amazing textures and fresh aromatic
flavors to excite the palette
add one part pre-rinse quinoa to two
parts cold water if you're not using
pre-rinsed the quinoa grains should be
soaked before use to remove their bitter
coating
bring to a simmer and cook for about 20
minutes until the water is absorbed
spoon the cooked quinoa onto a plate and
spread out to cool
[Music]
meanwhile dry roast flaked almonds in a
frying pan
once golden add raisins
chop mint
and spring onions
strips off skin from a whole cucumber to
make Stripes then remove the seeds and
chop into Half Moon Slices
add half cherry tomatoes and the cooled
quinoa
and gently mix in with your fingers
[Music]
season with salt and pepper
dress with a good squeeze of lime and
drizzle of olive oil
finish with a few fresh mint leaves
and for my ultimate light lunch I'm
doing another delicious salad with shea
fennel
the secret here
is the peel the outside that gets rid of
that firm skin it starts to sort of
brighten up a little bit
almost like the sun's come out
once you've discarded the outer layer
gently shave off thin strips of fennel
for your salad
the advantage of having this nice and
thin is because it's like these
wonderful thin fennel crisps
fragrant delicious peel them in to your
ice water
this can be done a couple of hours
before you want to eat this will
preserve the fennel's fresh flavor and
make it lovely and crisp
[Music]
drain the fennel
look at it beautiful
complement the fennel a delicious
dressing starting with chopped coriander
fennel and lime go brilliant you well
together zest over the fennel and then
use all the goodness inside the lime
lightly season it
dressed with the leftover grapefruit
marinade from the ceviche followed by a
drizzle of olive oil
it's delicious
marinating away the beautiful stunning
fennel salad and that goes brilliantly
well with a quinoa
packed full of flavor butts incredibly
light and very healthy no wonder I'm so
thin
[Music]
when I'm developing new recipes
I take my inspiration from all over the
world discovering fantastic new
ingredients and cooking techniques is
what really keeps me excited about food
and for my ultimate light dinner I put
together some great flavors to make
dishes really fresh and bright
feta and watermelon salad for starters
and a beautifully light dessert of lemon
and basil granita
but we're starting with the delicious
main course griddled chicken with
chickpeas in a lemony dressing
[Music]
and Holly is going to be lending me a
hand
your favorite chicken thighs first of
all
let's turn on the grill reason why we're
using the thighs I.E the brown meat if
so it doesn't go dry the seasoning nice
salt pepper olive oil and turn them over
please
can't get your hands in there good don't
worry about your nail guns so there's no
bones in there so the chicken will cook
really quickly
why did you do it skin side down skin
side down first that'll stop the chicken
from going dry and it'll get it really
nice and crispy
good see the way it's marked the skin
now yeah it's all that really nice
flavor in there as well and we'll just
turn them every two or three minutes how
much do you love chicken Plus lots
you'll serve that some really nice
chickpeas so it's all going to make a
little dressing okay one nice teaspoon
of mustard in please
a little bit of olive oil
a touch of salt
and pepper
give that a really good mix
and then you just squeeze Lots
of lemon juice in there a little taste
that's nice that is delicious
now look at that chicken now
beautiful nice and crispy as well turn
the gas down now and leave that chicken
to griddle right let's get the chickpeas
done shall we yeah
so we've got peculio Peppers so these
are roasted smoked Spanish Peppers now a
little taste
I would like you chop up the cadaveras
you take off the the top I'm going to
slice them in half like that wash your
fingers I will okay so these are small
tequila Peppers yeah it's a bit sweeter
there you go put your fingers please
wash your fingers please tuck them in
three finger rule come on Holly you know
the three finger rule I've been telling
you that since six months old good girl
you're fast honey yeah
in fact you're faster than Jack don't
tell him go get them upset the top is in
yes please thank you good I'm gonna give
it a little mix for your fingers
please
love it rump holes
come on out out get out every time this
food is always there he smells it from
mile away
a chicken's grilling it's inside down
why is it on skin side down because it
keeps getting moist she's really nice
and moist that's right now we'll start
the watermelon salad watermelon feta
cucumber pan nice and hot get the pecans
okay and just sort of break them up I'm
going to start slicing the watermelon do
you keep the seeds in yeah fine so you
just made these little boats
and go around like that now with a
toasted pecans give them a little
seasoning would you please Red Pepper
too
um no just touch your salt thank you
rolling around and just start seeing
smoking see now turn the gas off please
we're just going to take half the
cucumber and give that a little peel for
me please
that's a nicely dry roasted
take them off so from there I want you
then to slice around the seeds
that's the watery part okay we'll keep
that out
wash your fingers please
nice
am I still faster than Jack you are
still very fast
a lot faster than Jack now cucumber on
top of the melon we'll mix up in a
minute I want to give that a nice little
light seasoning Touch of salt a little
touch of Pepper please
Crush those little bits pecans in there
for me
nice
next Greek feta cheese
this is kind of easy isn't it
fat and long snoring hurry up mate take
them out fat lazy lump snoring his head
off come on out
so I've got that nice juicy melon the
cucumber and now the cheese we need
something to bring it to life
that's sumac okay that is very citrusy
we're just gonna season that lightly
now what I want you to do is sprinkle
the pecans in there
what's up
basil mint mint sorry minty
you get confused and pass it with your
boyfriend
no Daddy okay good keep it that way for
the 10 years fresh mint over and then
a little drizzle
of olive oil okay don't mix it yet I
know you're dying to get in there aren't
you and just some fresh lemon juice
why'd you roll it it starts to release
all the juice let's now feel it
so it's less firm a little bit more
squidgy
no it's all that lemon juice coming out
now
want me to do
what do you taste everything yummy it's
fresh isn't it so that's the salad done
next our refreshingly light dessert of
lemon and basil granita
start by putting the juice of seven
lemons
and the zester one into a small pan
with a sprinting of caster sugar
stir over medium heat until the sugar
dissolves
dilute your granita mix with a little
water
[Music]
pour into a freezer proof container stir
in a good handful of chopped fresh basil
and place covered in the freezer for
three hours
when the granita is frozen around the
edges lightly break up the mixture with
a fork
return to the freezer and repeat twice
until the granito is Frozen with a
granular texture spoon into chilled
serving glasses garnish each with a
sprig of Basil
[Music]
amazingly light and refreshing lemon and
basil granita
with our granita and feta salad done and
The Griddle chicken beautifully charred
we can put the final touches to our main
course
I'll take the chicken
look how juicy that is see what I'm
going to do now with a basil is to get
big leaves
I just want to tear them in there
there you go
and start lifting the chicken up please
and putting it in the chickpeas
oh that juicy amazing chicken
remember this little baby here
a vinaigrette the heat of the chicken
will Infuse the basil because the
chicken's nice and warm
Mouse the basil and turn this salad into
something really delicious
doesn't see how we've flanged the
chicken
[Music]
plant
how gorgeous is that very got a roasted
pepper flavor fresh basil there's
wonderful chickpeas with the cater
berries I think Jack will like this one
you think Jack will like this one yeah
yeah and Megan
until even ready
interesting let's go
well done
[Music]
this is my ultimate light dinner
griddle chicken thighs with chickpeas
and a lemony dressing
feta and watermelon salad
and for a refreshingly zingy end to the
meal lemon and basil granita
[Music]
Jack yep Maggie
Tilly let's go
[Music]
can't wait to dig in so Pals scale of
one to ten how easy is this ten will you
be doing it again for me excellent great
colors beautiful colors
it's pretty good with a knife
seriously than Jack faster than Jack is
there a little bit of competition going
on Chutney worried you've been taken
over by your twin
because she's not no she's not no tails
how is it
Meg is it the kind of dish you can see
cooking for your boyfriend one day
um
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the App Store good luck
[Music]
okay today it's all about healthy food I
love running marathons and playing sport
so this subject's very close to my heart
healthy food has a bit of a bad
reputation being slightly boring and
Bland but it doesn't have to be and
that's one of the keys to maintaining a
good diet you need to make food that's a
pleasure to eat as well as being healthy
packed with flavor here's more of my
ultimate healthy food
for breakfast my secret to amazing
healthy granola made in minutes and full
of goodness next a quick and easy
healthy lunch bursting with flavor and
brimming with lean protein steamed
mussels with cherry tomatoes and saffron
crisp breads
for dinner incredible spicy lamb chops
with superfoods broccoli and bulgur
wheat and a vitamin packed healthy mango
sundae proof that food that is good for
you can taste great these are more of my
ultimate healthy recipes breakfast lunch
and dinner
foreign
granola for breakfast
every time I put a healthy recipe
together a healthy dish it needs a bit
of a treat so this is a lovely stunning
get up and go fresh granola first thing
in the morning
treat here
is in that little baby honey so that
sweetens it so just start off with 200
mil
of delicious honey
into a pan just to warm up and she goes
now I know these are a chef's favorite
but it makes all the difference
especially for breakfast a fresh
vanilla pod and I think of the way that
I use herbs to add flavor to soups and
salads
I like to think the vanilla does exactly
the same
scrape out all those wonderful seeds in
now
staple of the granola
is the oats next
[Music]
puff rice delicious crunchy it was light
and fluffy next add wheat bran and your
seeds pumpkin sunflower and linseed and
then almonds
incredible that nice heavyweight
from the nut bunch
now bring the honey to the ball
slowly drizzle that amazing honey
in
give that a really good mix coat the
granola with the hot honey just slowly
Churn it using the outside of the bowl
you can see it just really nice and
sticky
once the granola is completely coated in
honey it's ready to bake
now spread the mix on baking paper I'm
going to season it lightly with a touch
of salt on top
the salt throughout dries up the oats
and the Honey will roast
color and glaze
the granola
nice into the oven for 25 to 30 minutes
[Music]
10 minutes into the cooking simply run a
spoon across the top to turn the mix and
ensure it's crunchy all over
smell that light
rose look at the color honestly well
it's crispy it's delicious
now I'm going to start it up and put
some lovely dried cranberries that just
gives us chewy
sweet flavor delicious and then finally
these beautiful berries
Goji berries Goji berries are high in
antioxidants and have been eating China
for centuries for their healing
properties but you can add any dried
fruit you like the cranberry and the
Goji berries gives it that nice chewy
Rich texture to the granola
now this is the best way to store it it
looks incredible
really incredible go ahead
that eat well stay well
right
milk
my homemade crunchy granola it looks
good tastes good and it's packed with
healthy grains superfood berries and
seeds it's incredibly good for you too
at breakfast for champions
thank you
next I'll be showing you a fantastic
healthy lunch and dinner
there are no Magic ingredients just
great fresh food here's a closer look at
what you'll need to make them
[Music]
first up for lunch one of my favorite
ingredients mussels they're great value
an excellent source of nutrients and
lean protein and they are so versatile
you can poach them Grill them or bake
them but I'm gonna steam them with
cherry tomatoes pancetta Sherry and
chili for lunch
good
my next healthy ingredient is bulgur
wheat richer in protein fiber and
minerals than many other grains The
Nutty flavored bulgur wheat is made by
par boiling drying then grinding whole
wheat it's fantastic in puddings in
stuffings or in salads like the charred
broccoli one I'll be serving for dinner
[Music]
finally not strictly an ingredient but
it certainly adds flavor The Griddle pan
perfect for grilling almost anything
with minimum oil and maximum taste plus
excess fat just drains away you can find
them for as little as 10 pounds trust me
it's worth the investment and takes veg
Meat and Fish to another healthy level
[Music]
chefs are renowned for working all hours
and having unhealthy Lifestyles but I
try to keep myself fit and eat healthily
and it's not as difficult as you might
think so however busy your life is I'm
going to prove to you you don't need to
always go for fast food already meals
it's easy to cook fantastic healthy
meals at home here's my ultimate healthy
lunch fast to cook but crammed with
flavor a delicious saffron flatbread
with mussels it doesn't get any healthy
than that first job the super easy
saffron flatbread
put the saffron into the bowl
and a couple of teaspoons of hot water
that starts to infuse
the saffron
and so you can maximize on the color
across your flatbreads to make the dough
simply add plain flour a pinch of salt
and pepper to a bowl and then pour in a
dash of olive oil
that makes the dough nice and silky and
Rich you'll saffron water you'll see how
concentrated it is now
and you'll need cold water
then simply need to bring the dough
together mop up all your flour
you can see now
saffron's activated it's got that really
nice color
useful
use your wrist
and just knead it nicely we'll do now is
smoothing out the gluten strands
push
and tuck in
push and tuck in and each every time you
do this getting softer you just sort of
form
this perfect beautiful
though
it smells delicious that saffron is a
powerful
now
sit that in your bowl cover your
clinical let it rest for 10 to 15
minutes
this relaxes the dough making it easier
to roll and gives it time to infuse with
the saffron I'm gonna cut that into
three and then roll them nice and thinly
now lightly flour surface
and then just
bring that
it's like a perfect ball
on the board
I want to go that nice ball your rolling
pin
and just roll it out
now
it doesn't get any simpler than that
and just lightly
flour that on top
a little salt
cooking the flatbread is easy just pop
in a hot dry pan and they're ready in
minutes as it hits the pan it starts to
blister
is ready for turning
beautiful get that color on there
now you want it nice and crisp almost
blistering on both sides because it's
nice and thin it's cooked once browned
on both sides just cool on a rack
flatbreads done now onto the muscles now
the secret
behind cooking
great mussels is in the speed you're
cooking
key is to chop and prep your ingredients
before you start cooking
first thing I'm chatter I want it quite
chunky if you can't get pancetta I
always like to use a sort of streaky
bacon
because I want to sort of render all
that flavor
and add this tricky bacon
now Tomatoes garlic and chili
cherry tomatoes that's just going in
whole the garlic
just crush the garlic
it's all that flavor comes out chili
I want some heat in here
that's everything prepped now to get it
cooked a little touch
of olive oil
pancetta in
pancetta takes moments once it's brown
and crisp put your garlic chili and
whole cherry tomatoes into the pan
mussels go in
okay and I'm using dry sherry I think it
works better in this recipe than white
wine which is classically used at this
stage then oregano finely chopped stalks
and all I go on
and then just give that
a little mix
and see those muscles start to open lid
goes on
you've got to lock in that flavor gotta
lock in that heat the mussels will take
four to five minutes to steam in the
meantime cut your flatbreads into strips
crispy
and crunchy
now the mussels
wow that is incredible
my goodness me
[Music]
now that is one lunch I definitely don't
want to miss
healthy and delicious
doesn't get any better than that
incredible
steam mussels with saffron flatbreads
made in minutes and packed with protein
and vitamins this is one fast food meal
that really is healthy
[Music]
Health eating is all about Balance fresh
home-cooked food in sensible portions
with a few treats now and again my
ultimate healthy dinner is a great
balance of protein carbs vegetables and
fruit but doesn't compromise on taste or
flavor
the key to healthy eating is to have a
host of wholesome recipes up your sleeve
so you're never short of inspiration
joining me to create this healthy dinner
is Jack's twin sister Holly
we've got aromatic lean lamb chops with
Char grilled broccoli and bulgur wheat
salad for dessert it's healthy mango
sundae Holly
[Music]
now
we all know that you love desserts yeah
yeah we'll do a little
yogurt parfait with some macerated
fruits so the first thing I'd like you
to do is to take a tablespoon
of icing sugar dust that over the fruits
good now is that enough that's perfect
dummy thank you zest the orange over the
fruits what's going to happen now it's
going to start to sort of marinate I'm
gonna put some basil in there
that'll make it really flavoursome
fresh puzzle in
and then I'm going to give that little
mix up I'm going to squeeze
some fresh orange juice in there nice
and gently
okay how gorgeous do those berries look
now very should we just leave them just
marinate okay and that's what we call
macerated berries now for the mango
sundae rice mangoes in please
I love mangoes
no they're naturally sweet okay
on
oh
that smells better
now how fresh does that smell sorry no
you love art right yeah I do so you're
gonna put these together so a nice
little dollop of mango at the bottom
nice and slowly once each glass has a
layer of mango puree at the bottom
spoon over a layer of thick natural
yogurt and Alternate until the glass is
full
you get your berries
you silly berries on top
it tastes so fresh
but now they've been marinated and the
berries have been slightly macerated and
then finally not
eat your rice and sugar and just tap
on top they
look it's beautiful now they sit in the
fridge to get nice
and chill Okay so
if I take three
and promise not to sneeze
and you take one open the fridge door
good job
chilling in the fridge now for the super
simple main course to go with the
aromatic lamb chops a tasty char grill
broccoli and bulgur wheat salad
cook the Bulgur wheat just simmer until
tender then drain
broccoli a Char grilled flavor simply
cooked with salt in a hot dry pan until
Smoky and tender
for a quick and easy aromatic dressing
mixed together Harissa paste with either
buttermilk or creme fraiche and add
chopped mint simple as that
to serve thoroughly dress your broccoli
and bulgur wheat and finish with more
fresh mint leaves
dessert ready and salads done now for
the aromatic grilled lamb chops
how much do you love lamb holes a lot a
lot on a scale of one to ten ten okay
these lamb chops are gonna be delicious
first we're going to marinade them I'll
start putting the spices in yeah first
one
coriander coriander good so teaspoon of
coriander seeds in and it'll touch off
what's that human human well done cumin
in one of Daddy's favorites
turmeric turmeric a teaspoon of that in
there
now a little touch of salt
and then I want you to start grinding
that down below I get the ginger and the
garlic
give that a nice little mix
please for Daddy
that looks amazing off that get the
garlic lay it flat
and not it almost purees the garlic so
we get a nice paste see it underneath
sorry about dirty your nails it's okay
nothing wrong with that
the more you smell of garlic the less
the boys are going to date you
sorry
right now the ginger
makes it sort of spicy and fruity now
get the ginger and do exactly same with
the ginger and you grate it like this it
turns into the most amazing Ginger puree
not for your dog
come on Holly put some muscle into it
look yeah
nice see all that there yeah black knife
drizzle some olive oil in there okay and
you bring that together as a paste for
Daddy there you go
no it'll come off
nice
good girl
now that smells incredible that is a
delicious paste so I'm going to tip
all that marinade on to the lamb and
then I want you to rub it all in to
those lamb chops
there we go get your hands in there my
girl
come on holes
so look you get them in there and you
rub all that marinade the the flavor
inside these chops come on Holly
come on your Jumper's fine
just smell that
nice fresh
and the earlier you do this the better
the turmeric is starting to stain the
lamb chops they're not even cooked yet
they smell delicious yeah
what do you like honestly Oh My Nails Oh
My Nails delicious after marinating from
10 minutes to overnight but if you can't
wait to get your hands on them you can
Grill the chops straight away gas nice
and high and Grilling them
it's going to make them slightly
healthier
so
lamb on
first one
in
we'll slide that in
alongside is that so you fit more in the
pan that's right what I want to do is
get those really nice
grill marks on there
[Music]
see
on
[Music]
now we're going to cook them
three sides one side up clip it and then
on the back see this bit here yeah a
little on there as well
[Music]
now if you could get the yogurt out of
the fridge please done it nice
some fresh mint
I'm going to pick
the mint please and give it a little
chop and mix it in with the yogurt
smells amazing
doesn't it
so yoga
and
chop up
the mint please have a look
at the color
of the Lamb
oh uh beautiful
[Music]
how nice
of a they smell incredible grilling them
this way they cook so much quicker okay
it's a lot healthier
smell those
beautiful you say this yes very
good I reckon Megan will like those I
hope so
see what I'm doing I'm standing the
chops up yeah and we're not going to dry
out this way
try a bit more that's fine and then mix
it into yogurt food darling
I'm not a salt my darling how would you
know when they're done nice and pink
three and a half to four minutes each
side
medium six minutes well done
eight or nine minutes
how would you like your lamb my darling
remember medium rare that's what I
always go for
a lamb cutlet at its best
would be medium red off with the gas
okay
so lovely lovely flavor
okay look at that wow I'm in heaven
I'll carry the lamb and the yogurt if
you get the bowler weeds and the
broccoli that smells incredible it
really does
to make
goodness and utterly delicious with a
bit of kitchen know-how you have my
ultimate healthy dinner on the table in
just 30 minutes
meal for any busy family
oh
yes please
oh wow that's very fancy look how proud
she is they look gorgeous Hall all right
holes they look amazing
beautiful oh look at the color that's
kind of blue pass it here for you but
after you've eaten all your broccoli
that's a long time away
it's delicious really really lovely
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the App Store good luck